almost everyone is familiar with what
apple is and what they are famous for
from their iphones to their imacs apple
has created a very exclusive digital
ecosystem for their customers even
though apple has a very isolated
ecosystem it doesn't mean they are not
very exclusive on the contrary apple is
a market leader in both the smartphone
market segment as well as the personal
computers market segment most of you
might not know but a few years back
apple tried to get their beak into the
automotive sector this project was a
complete failure back then but that
hasn't stopped apple from jumping back
into the car manufacturing game let us
take a look at the upcoming apple car
and why it will be a complete failure
the news surrounding apple cars the past
year doesn't increase confidence around
the whole project we now know that the
first version of the apple car was in
development since 2014 but since then it
has gone through so much turbulence that
apple had to totally scratch everything
and begin a new project during this time
apple had tried to engage companies like
hyundai nissan toyota and bmw in
partnership but the negotiations would
always fall apart apple car project was
also played with people leaving the
project all of this doesn't add
credibility to apple's aims to become a
trusted car brand let's go through some
of the project failures that apple car
has gone through and why this means that
apple car project might end up costing
apple billions without producing any
value apple car chief doug fields leaves
apple one of the most major blows apple
car project faced was one earlier this
month it was reported by bloomberg that
doug fields then head of apple's
electric car project left the company
for ford doug had been offered a
position as the chief advanced
technology and embedded systems officer
apple was really counting on fields to
finally lead the apple car project
toward the right track this is because
doug had expertise in the automotive
industry previously doug had worked with
tesla it was a crucial part of the tesla
model 3 project tesla model 3 is the
cheapest tesla electric vehicle yet
people at ford were pretty happy with
poaching doug from apple ford's ceo jim
farley went on the record to say that it
was a pretty good moment for ford to get
doug on their team and how he would be
an asset to ford sadly for apple they
were left without a leader for their
apple car project it seems like people
are more attracted towards projects with
more established automobile companies
like ford according to apple kevin lynch
will now lead the apple car project
lynch has been working at apple since
2013. before that lynch had worked at
adobe kevin has also worked on the apple
watch project but the problem is that
lynch doesn't have any expertise in the
automotive world this is not a good sign
for apple according to apple there are
some senior executive level people on
the apple car project that do have
automotive experience from the likes of
bmw and tesla doug fields abandoning the
apple car project isn't the first time
top talent is taking flight far away
from the apple car project top project
executives working on the apple car have
left two greener pastures these include
dave scott he was leading the team
working on apple car robotics dave left
apple car to become ceo of hyperfine a
cutting-edge technology company working
on a portable mr imaging device another
executive named jamie wado who had
previously been overlooking the safety
and regulation-based activities for the
apple car project also left apple
recently he is now serving as the cto
for canvue another company working on
digitizing the road and highway
infrastructure benjamin lyon was part of
apple car's original team when the
project started years back he also left
applecar and is now the chief engineer
at astra a private space launch company
according to bloomberg almost a dozen
top-level people have left the apple car
project this year this is not a good
sign for any project as top-level
executives leaving a project in such a
short period usually mean these
executives don't see a good future in
the project and there is potentially now
room for success or growth people don't
usually jump ship from a completely safe
ship they jump ship from vessels that
are sinking all of these people leaving
the apple car project certainly doesn't
inspire confidence in the project this
also creates uncertainty as management
goes through such turbulent times this
can result in a very uncertain direction
for the whole project it seems like
whenever you hear something new about
developments with the apple car project
it is always 180 degrees from what they
were planning previously for example
just take a look at the news coming out
about apple's plan on how they will
source their battery technology for
their apple car at first it was reported
by reuters that apple was in talks with
chinese battery makers to make the
batteries for the apple car the chinese
company they were looking to partner
with is called cattle and is the major
supplier for potential competitors for
apple cars in the electric vehicle
sector that is tesla and chinese
automaker byd but apple wants them to
build the manufacturing plant in the u.s
which considering the volatile relations
between china and the us seems very
unlikely to happen apple just can't seem
to convince any company to play along
the major concern for apple's car would
be its direct competitor in the u.s
market that is tesla motors tesla has
already dominated the ev market for
years now tesla already offers really
affordable high performance evs like the
tesla model 3. it would be really hard
for apple to come in and try to carve a
piece of that market for themselves
established companies like ford
volkswagen and bmw are having a hard
time trying to compete with tesla's
pricing features and overall
accessibility so a new auto manufacturer
like apple will have no chance of trying
to sell evs when companies like tesla
exist and continue to make great
electric vehicles the details on the new
apple car project are a little scarce
but here is what we know so far at the
start of this year we first had a
glimpse into the specifications for the
upcoming apple car this was when it was
reported that apple is in talks with the
korean car manufacturer hyundai to
partner up to make fully electric
vehicles according to seasoned analyst
ming chi quo who is a respected
authority on everything apple related
apple car would be partnering with
hyundai to take advantage of their
manufacturing capabilities apple will be
using hyundai's new electric car chassis
called the egmp chassis for their
upcoming car hyundai itself had
announced the egmp chassis a few months
ago according to details released by the
company the egmp chassis would be able
to do 300 miles on a single charge in
terms of charging times hyundai expects
its fast charging capabilities to charge
the vehicle to 80 percent in just 18
minutes this is really impressive by
industry standards it is even mentioned
that a single five minute charge will be
able to give 60 miles of range now that
is impressive and faster than any other
ev in the market but it is to be noted
that these are specifications released
by the company so we have to take these
claims with a grain of salt there is a
reason other electric vehicle giants
like tesla can't charge this fast this
is because the current level of
technology doesn't allow this level of
performance and scalability hyundai also
mentioned that the egmp platform can do
160 miles per hour top speed the
acceleration specs of the car would be 0
to 60 miles per hour in 3.5 seconds that
is pretty fast as well and is near other
high performance vehicles like the tesla
model s but this possible deal with
hyundai it seems won't yield any results
since hyundai now says they aren't in
talks with apple at all to make a car
this seems unfortunate for apple apple
may have seen great success in the world
of smartphones and personal devices like
laptops and the ipad but jumping
industries like this is often
challenging if not impossible from what
we have seen so far it seems like the
apple car project will just end up
draining apple if nothing else